somewhere honest avoid be storm power
here the ASCAP Expo 2013 shut up the new
media rockstars ah we're getting it papa
there's free drinks I mean everyone who
makes anything related to audio and
music has a little like booth in section
here so so there's a lot of fun just
walking around this is a packed house
today so I was a little nervous coming
on but I was actually glad that there's
a moderator up there you know to control
what's going on you know what I mean so
we don't end up going on a tangent or
like me end up talking about like random
things you know what I mean so yeah it's
pretty cool it was this one hot girl a
troll see yeah it might be my first time
being around like all these
professionals I guess you know we're
mostly around you know our fans and
fellow artists doing at shows and things
like that you know what I mean so I'm
definitely here to learn a lot more and
definitely got a little bit of insight
on their on their journeys on Kurt and
DeStorm and Ally's as well the truth is
there there's no secret it's just
putting stuff out into the world and
doing it over and over again until you
get your breaks somewhere so you know
everyone's story who's successful online
is they did something they believed in
and they kept doing it until they they
got somewhere because you know no one
puts up a video and just like becomes a
star overnight it seems that way to the
to the world but that's because they put
up 20 more videos before then and then
finally one of them takes off and then
all your sudden you're like oh my god
this guy became a star overnight so you
know I I learned a lot of cool stories
which is always fun and I'm always
worried about like the next generation
you know what I mean which is why I
always like to push the original
movement you know ASCAP it's all about
songwriting and things like that so it's
really good to be here for that but um
yeah especially for asian-americans I
think you know they are not as visible
in the media in the mainstream media so
I'd love to just keep doing what I'm
doing and in that process like helping
people get out there more as
well and hopefully bridging that gap
between the YouTube world and and
mainstream as few have done so before
you know like Justin Bieber and and
Carmen and things like that but uh I
think it's really cool to be a part of
that as well nowadays I think more
people go to YouTube for music than
anywhere else I mean there's I mean
obviously there was myspace but there's
tons of things like Spotify and
everything else but if you want to cure
a song most people turn to YouTube I
think that's only gonna become more so
and there's more YouTube views a day now
than ever if you're a musician you got
to embrace it
man I got a EP coming out next week
hopefully gonna be doing a little thing
with new media rockstars and yeah it
comes out 5/5 tracks which is cool in
they're all brand new so a little Street
for the fans but also I haven't put out
something in two years so it's yeah
coming out wow it's soon in a week April
23 April 23 check it out I think I'm
gonna be trying to do something Mike
Tyson which is kind of awesome long as
he don't knock me the [ __ ] out I've been
I've been in talks with doing something
with a few other traditional media cats
like I just did the Taye Diggs video and
I'm doing some with other traditional
media artists also so you know I got a
lot of surprises I don't want to ruin it
for everybody but I want people to just
I like people to tune into my channel my
goal when are you work with them you
know I like that type of [ __ ] so that's
pretty cool
well I'm producing an original album
with Sam and that's coming out within a
month and always more videos you know
trying to do a video week sometimes it
ends up being every other week but
hopefully hopefully some of its fun and
people like it we're gonna work on
someone we always discuss working on
some we've been do me a kirpan cut my
working on something for years you know
and of course AJ you know we're gonna
work on something soon anyway ya know
it's just I think it's just about
finding the time to do it cuz we're all
that lives are so busy and we're always
working on other projects I got like
four projects going on now so you know
it just becomes that you know time thing
now we got all our contact info and
stuff like that so we're gonna be
sharing info sharing ideas hopefully and
yeah look out for a possible collab what
up guys this is Kurt Schneider and this
is
Media rockstars yo what's up guys I'm AJ
Rafael just wanted a shout outs and new
media rockstars love y'all peace